what's up everyone my name is Gabriel
mr. tacos way I opened up my restaurant
six years ago the one thing that
everybody comes back for besides my
tacos are my micheladas which I call the
Miche way tacos way it came from a slang
word from the street I come from Mexico
from a part where we use the word way
all the time
it means like hey what's up fool what's
up homie what's up buddy I'll be showing
you an easy version of a michelada that
you could do at home with your friends
watching sports or just hanging out but
I'm gonna show you guys how to make the
most extreme Atilla my way the meet your
way then I'm gonna call some friends up
for a drink but they will not be
expecting this let's do it let's go
first up is my recipe of a michelada
that you'll find at tacos way this
recipe right here is the one that made
me fall in love with a michelada the
first thing I do is put some more here I
remember with some boy and then we go to
the chili salt well let me tell Allah
originated in Mexico in the late 80s
Early 90s and it's still very popular
now we're loading up with some ice
around half ways and then we have the
michelada mix s Clamato freshly squeezed
lime chew more salt and has some little
secret stuff in there but with what I
just mentioned it'll make a great
michelada you get your beer of your
choice make sure you stir it in there so
you get all the flavors this is very
important you guys when you stirring it
you make sure it's all the way in I put
a lime here
cucumber some shrimp in Mexico they have
meetcha bars that just sell micheladas
and it's getting very popular over here
United States - at the Dodger games many
many people are asking for michelada to
top it off we use chamoy this product
comes from Mexico it's a like sour candy
it's really good because they're good a
good taste
throw some chilli salt in there
and this is how you make the
world-famous michelada the meat your
wave from tacos way if you think this
looks good
wait and see what's coming I'm gonna
show you guys the biggest the baddest
the most extremely chilla you've ever
seen okay I'm gonna get started it's
almost the same thing but it's bigger
and it's better make sure you get all
the chilli sauce right here on the rim
next we put the ice in here so they can
be the freshest michelada meat you mix
so again it has Clamato freshly squeezed
lime salt chamoy that's all you need for
a good michelada for this extremely
chill allah for the big mitchell allah
we're gonna use for 32 ounce beers it
doesn't really matter what time you
drinking michelada even in the mornings
is the best to drink a michelada when
you're hungover so you could get drunk
with michelada and then you could get
cured with a michelada so it's kind of
weird but the michelada does everything
so good for the chips around here I'm
gonna go ahead and put some lime here
some cucumber some shrimp dressed it up
make it look really good like I said
it's not only a good michelada it's also
a good snack when you're drinking you
gotta get hungry too
all I do I get hungry when I'm drinking
we just got to put a little more flavor
to it you have some temor here after I
do this I'm gonna call my friends and
surprise them with this mega michelada I
hope they like it
well I think this looks amazing here I
recommend you don't drink it by yourself
invite your friends don't be tight
wherever you do this it'll be a party
for sure
and now it's time to drink with my
friends
[Applause]
[Music]